salut bienvenue dans cette vidéo casse
tête avant de commencer à laisser moi
vous dire que la vidéo d'aujourd'hui
sponsorisé par haut doubs et là je sais
vous allez me dire oui c'est fabien
c'est quoi au doux qu'est ce que ça fait
dans une vidéo castex et bien eau douce
est une suite de produits numériques à
destination de la gestion d'entreprise
des grands mots pour dire que c'est des
logiciels qui accompagne les entreprises
pour simplifier leur gestion quotidienne
qui est pour le moins 1 ça si vous avez
une entreprise vous savez c'est à
castets voilà donc il ya du sens aux
doux accompagne également la création de
sites web et aux doux vous permet la
création d'un site gratuit avec
l'hébergement et le support inclus
d'ailleurs pendant la première année
d'abonnement votre nom de domaine
personnalisé et offert ce qui vous
laisse le temps de prendre vos marques
et de faire votre place
le site web rapide à configurer surtout
facile d'utilisation avec un petit
système drag and drop qui vous permet
une vraie fluidité de travail et enfin
haut doubs propose un business model
original moi je connaissais pas c'est la
gratuité à vis du produit si vous
utilisez une application unique et dès
la seconde application la suite devient
criante avec une facturation par
application et ça ça permet de vous
créer votre propre écosystème de gestion
en fonction de vos besoins à vous
autrement dit eau douce est une solution
totalement modulable qui vous permet une
facilité de gestion une réduction des
prises de têtes valsent et - casquette
si vous voulez en savoir plus sur la
création de sites web avec aude où je
vous ai mis un lien dans la description
deux titres ces deux pilotes briques
t'as déjà peser un cadenas de 2 kg
tu mettant le réseau était musclée à la
ferme bienvenue dans cette vidéo casse
tête c'est pas l'accent du tout de
thibaut rien à [ __ ] des excuses ça mon
pote c'est le tri club 13 2 kg d'acier
inoxydable et de laiton
est ce qu'on est prêt à le résoudre
les tons tient à c
[Musique]
on est prêt à le résoudre alors qu'au
moment même où je vous parle je suis sur
scène à marseille ce marseille pour
l'avant dernière date de en création
mais du coup je vais plus parler de
spectacle etc pendant quelques mois
parce que on prépare justement le
nouveau spectacle avec la tournée et
j'ai décidé pour cette nouvelle tournée
que c'est moi qui vous préviendrai quand
je viendrai chez vous parce qu'à chaque
fois on me dit ouais j'avais pas vu
passer tu vois quand même nous prévenir
c'est à moi de vous prévenir y'a pas de
problème c'est moi qui vous prévient
quand je passe chez vous que vous
habitiez en france ou à l'étranger peu
importe vous habitez pour ça je vous
mets un lien en fait dans la description
ou vous inscrivez et vraiment je vous
enverrai un mail le jour où je passe
dans le coin en spectacle ou en
rencontres ou en dédicace ou en tournage
en ça va être plus simple pour
communiquer vous et moi que les réseaux
sociaux qui n'affiche que ce qu'ils
veulent quand ils veulent ouais je
dénonce je peux parler par un tueur aig
en a rien à [ __ ] qu'on refasse un
tournage
il a été créé en 2021 ce casse tête par
renner pop pop pop et le thé 13 puisque
c'est le tri clock 13 - l'appel de thé
13 il a été à la base inspiré par le thé
12 et à prendre le thé 10 jusqu'au t1
qui a été le premier que reinhardt pop à
fabriquer level 10 e sur 10 ou six sur
six selon l'insoluble kcap level trop
loin trop elle savait qu'elle est un peu
longue cette intro je vous donnerai plus
d'infos sur le casse tête au fur et à
mesure mais j'ai envie de m'y attaquer
alors il ya une clé ya une serrure on se
dit quoi on se dit qu'on a bien envie de
l'ouvrir oh bah dis donc ça nous a ça
n'ouvre pas le casse tête par contre
qu'il ya eu un petit déclencheur au bout
allez c'est parti bon là quand je mets
la clé de dents à gauche je suis en
butée à droite j'ai juste là
tout petit truc de jeu comme ça possible
c'est de déplacer la serrure parce que
je me souviens on a fait un cadenas une
fois dans la serrure se déplacer
qu'est ce qu'on a ici on a ça alors ça
je sais qu'il faut absolument pas le
dévissé j'ai des infos sur le casse tête
pas de gravité pas de choc pas de force
et surtout ne pas dévisser lévis duo
mais celle ci autant je l'annoncé
sévices lâche principes dont il parlait
pas parce que celle ci elle bouge ça
bouge pas est ce là ça bouge ça du coup
c'est il ya juste la consigne pour cela
de lire on ne les touche pas on leur
fait pas de mal la la ça on peut appuyer
là-dessus
là on peut peut-être appuyer là-dessus
c'est pas sûr mais ça bouge un petit peu
et puis après paya rien notre coin alors
comment il est constitué les constitué
d'un seul bloc ici en laiton et d'un ici
donc peut-être peut-être ça peut bouger
aussi ouvrir la possiblement ça peut
bouger au s'ouvrir la presse a peut-être
on peut appuyer là-dessus également ya
pas il n'y a pas énormément de
possibilités renner papy s'est inspiré
des vues des verrous de permutations de
henry hicham en 1845 je crois et après
il a construit le t1 qui était réputée
impossible à offrir parce qu'il y avait
0 logique dedans et du coup il s'est dit
choqué je vais faire quelque chose qui
est ouvrable qu'on arrive à comprendre
et ça c'est le thé 13 parce qu'il ya
treize mouvements pour réussir à jouer
et les pièces sont pas donnés
c'est super lourd à manipuler les pièces
sont pas données du tout parce que je
vais essayer de faire ça en appuyant de
l'autre côté en même temps les pièces
sont pas données du tout c'est entre
1600 et 2000 euros parce qu'ils les
sortent pas à la chaîne quoi évidemment
qu'on avait ce petit trou ici aussi
aarau j'avais pas vu ça en fait justifie
au dessus là entre le point et la
serrure il ya tout petit qui est ce
assez de l'acier alors que le reste en
laiton voilà je sais pas à quoi ça sert
mais je peux pas je peux pas faire
grand-chose en vrai qu'il ya ceux aussi
qui bouge le shaq et à l'arrière on peut
le faire tourner la sauce ce petit
cercle déjà je vais essayer de bien
m'être droit et de rouvrir
donc ça ça fait rien si je le mets à
90° 20 45 la du couple
d'amis si je me mets à 180 degrés
oh oh oh oh
la vache j'ai fait un tour complet là à
non à aux boîtes de fake donc là j'ai
été complètement à l'envers et et j'ai
tourné j'ai cru faire un tour complet on
va je fais des tours complets même si ça
frotte un peu mais surtout il ya ça là
il ya tout le bloc supérieur qui s'est
décalé et qui se décale encore
d'ailleurs vers la vers le haut je pense
que c'est la première étape donc là
celle-là ouvert un peu comme ça qu'est
ce que ça me donne d'autres maintenant
il ya toujours ce truc là
celui ci que je peux bouger et ces trucs
là il n'y a pas énormément d'endroits où
chose
qu'il a donné
l'impression qu'il a fait trois
positions on va commencer à faire appel
aux vignettes les biens
agents lunettes agents lunettes oui vous
porter immédiatement aux missions ne me
décevez pas quand vous dites
immédiatement c'est à dire tout de suite
c'est pour olic à orly car c'est quoi un
service de bus qui
aurait dû partir en mission tu pars en
mission s'est vu
et
attend il ya ça aussi qui ok bah c'est
qu'on put 1 j'avais eu des mots tout
début tu as assez souvent ça dans les
hypothèses de castets je dis un truc et
après je pense plus ça ça tourne la
voyez mes doigts c'est pas mes doigts
qui glisse et l'ensemble de qui tourne
un peu comme une bague n'y a rien de
spécial on peut le tourner à fond il ya
un point de but et j'ai l'impression on
peut le tourner indéfiniment
ok amelia déclic 1,1
point
c'est très dur et ceinture
il ya des endroits où ça fera plus que
2,6 glv comme ça vous l'entendez
il y en a un en haut
ça devait être sa position de départ il
y en a
il y en a 5 ans va donc là il devait
être en haut je pense je vais essayer de
le mettre en bois donc 1 à 5 ans bac 2
quand ils les clips et il bouge pas quoi
près
de 3 là j'ai dû faire un 180 degrés
pourquoi 180 degrés je me dis pourquoi
pas et surtout comme on avait tourné le
ch à 180 degrés me dis que peut-être un
truc à faire avec ça
tout bouge et où tout ce qui ne semble
pas du même bloc faut que j'essaie de le
bouger ça je pensais que c'était usines
et avec est en fait maintenant c'est une
bague quoi c'est c'est vraiment c'est
très bien fait c'est très très fort
[Musique]
la jeune tester les cinq positions
j'ai testé juste à chaque fois de le
mettre sur une déposition de fermer et
d'ouvrir avec la clé je vais réessayer
ça mais à chaque fois en rajoutant des
contraintes du style bouger salle de
tournai appuyé l'appui elle va essayer
là qu'ils sont les seuls endroits les
identifie comme étant mobile
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
what the fuck j'étais en train de
tourner la clé et là j'ai essayé à caen
il n'est pas complètement ray en font
c'est parce qu'ils bloquaient avec le
truc et en tournant
en fait je me suis aperçu que away au
hockey il ya un endroit où j'ai pu
commencer à le tirer
et voilà c'est celui-là ok moi je
pensais que c'est parce que j'étais en
train d'appuyer sur le chat mais pas du
tout et là je peux virer le sco c'est
une espèce de cylindres alors ça je
m'attendais à pas mal de trucs mais pas
du tout à ça je faire gaffe à palper t
ah oui à l'intérieur il ya ça c'est
crantée rien qui bouge de spécial de
dans là c'est le truc j'ai voulu vous
faire voir tout à l'heure quand j'y
arrivais pas dallas bagués ne bouge plus
et donc j'ai réussi à sortir ce petit
cylindre là je sais pas ce que je vais
devoir faire avec ça c'est pas simple
c'est vraiment pas simple ces blocs et
que si je le débloquer je le mets dans
le trou là on voit que ce que c'est
bloqué avec ça et je me dis peut-être il
faut le tourner un petit peu je ne sais
pas je sais pas du tout comment faire
donc je vais essayer de faire ce que je
viens de vous faire voir si ça c'est
peut-être se dévisser ouais c'était
celle d'elvis à l'envers
[Musique]
ou
alors il faut leur emboîter dans un
autre sens peut-être comment comment on
peut savoir ça ah oui moi je m'arrête et
je me suis dit l'idée ce serait
peut-être de faire ça comme ça il est
tendu de fou un seul en
même temps je comprends je comprends le
le prix de l'objet tu vois la finesse du
trucage pas revissé ah oui c est
peut-être que avec ça peut-être qu'on a
des choses qui sont différemment si je
leur emboîtent parce que là
rien ne
se passe pas grand chose en plus je le
comprenne bien je prends comme sortir
[ __ ] ça me fait des frayeurs parce que
je me dis ça situe le bloc s'est passé
pas de petites boîtes en bois mon côté
j'essaye de regarder si ça fait des
moues vous pas quand je bouge la bague à
l'intérieur pour essayer de comprendre
comment il fonctionne en fait là d un
grenelle il bouge pas du tout par contre
il ya un vrai bail avec ce bouton là
mais qui est bloqué en fait par quelque
chose qui est ici là ah oui d'accord
entre les hôpitaux là j'ai réussi à
enfoncer ok là j'ai réussi à enfoncer
lui parce que avec le bout de la clé
voilà il ya un tout petit beat ou new la
bonne alors je te pouvoir le faire à
plat comme un tout petit bloquant de la
partie en acier que j'ai que j'ai poussé
avec la clé comme comme on pousserait sa
grand mère dans les eaux arctiques par
exemple idéaux mamie et donc ça ça me
libère un accès qui me permet de
repousser
dedans
un maître du coup pour re rentrer c'est
un intérieur va falloir que ça repousse
dans l'autre sens
faire un cercle complet avec les petits
même temps en gardant ma théorie de luy
jot mais là ça voudrait dire qu'il
faudrait mettre
voit la vache fait n'importe quoi
peut-être moi je me dis que si ça ça
ferait comme ça et là je fais ça comme
ça je continue à faire mon tour 30 et et
du coucher en sorte que ça continue
encore ce serait ça l'idée là ça fait un
tour complet dedans parce qu'on peut
leur mettre dedans
déjà j'aimerais question si la réponse
est non ça donne une réponse compliqué
et c'est compliqué c'est très très
chiant en fait parce qu'on est pas sûr à
castets qui va me faire un peu serré
ses proies qui bloque ses salles donc là
j'aime le remonter le même cercle mais à
l'envers en inversant pour voir ça ça me
donne envie de d'ouvrir une chaîne
youtube où je ferais que des lego c1 je
fais juste ce qu'il ya de marquer ça
passait là ça passe j'ai déjà
l'impression d'avoir fait les 13 les
treize mouvements là
chants et les lourds il est lourd comme
son poil pas sûr d'aller au bout de ce
messager vie était un
parce que je les aime aimerait aller à
ranger dans un ordre non c'est pas
ça c'est rien ça ça
moi j'ai l'impression d'avoir fait les
trois quarts
je peux sortir je peux pas le sortir ils
sauront ils surent pas la commune est
comme ça hiro sort aubry s'est passé un
truc c'est pas trop vers quoi en fait
quand je tournais la taxe ne met que la
fin il y avait comme de la résistance si
je lâchais la clé ça revenait mais en
fait j'ai tourné je sais pas si ce qu'il
faut faire ou pas j'ai tourné sa relevé
géré forcé ce que serra puis j'ai senti
cette résistance j'y suis allé jusqu'au
bout en permanence j'appuie sur les deux
boutons voir ce qui se passe et là ça
s'est enfoncé et du coup ça me l'a
ressorti la différence entre les deux
c'est qu'à un moment donné avec mon truc
d'engrenages que gérer arrangé pour
faire un cercle entier il s'est passé
quelque chose puisque quand je tournais
la clé je pouvais pas la retenir donc
j'ai changé une position à l'intérieur
je n'aime pas ce casse tête je n'ai même
pas ce casse tête mais j'aime les
casse-têtes c'est pas le problème mais
humainement je l' ai pas fini il tuèrent
j'aime pas quand il n'y a pas un
marqueur me disant tu es sur la bonne
voie fabien où tu te trompe fabre est
sur la bonne voie t'inquiète pas tu
je travaille en fait
si j'arrive à leur ouvrir je leur
montrais sur tik tok comme ça on passera
enfin le million d'abonnés soit mais si
je le louvre en une seule vidéo je ferai
la remise directement sur le sur les
documents qu'on est à 950 mille
personnes sur tik tok
et c'est bien violent je met ma tronche
lance un
jeu la résolution du grand scientifique
top le jour où tu me fais à une mare
ning routing gommage hockey gommage du
visage
quel sera le plus
moi ça me dérangera moins que toi jean
d'un côté dans l'image telle la
résolution de castets et 9 août
avez vous déjà vu
[Musique]
maintenant oui
et du coup après il ya une présentation
de casse tête avec toi à côté qui fait
un petit gommage serre-tête en slip
jeu 5 à son boxeur le faire une posture
qui
fait ce qu'il peut
[Musique]
fabriquer ce tube non non on fait ça
pour rigoler des cassettes des caméras
qu'on allume sa
me fais pipi
vivez votre life un moment donné ça fait
mille ans que je suis dessus at arrivera
là demain virginie je serai encore là
d'ailleurs
un bal à ces examens
mais six rangs france pitra oui c'est
parce que le bouton est ressorti à temps
waouh [ __ ] ça se trouve que j'ai abîmé
un truc il faut que je refasse tout
s'est passé un truc parce que qu'est-ce
qu'il ya qu'est-ce qui se passe ouais
ouais
ils regardent plus
moi je peux pas tout faire seul set ça
pèse 2 kg 7 shit
compris comment en sortir non mais il se
passe des trucs c'est tata entendu ça
fait un retour
ça fait cinq fois je réfute hélas
j'essayais de tour offert sans jamais
forcer non pas que je forçais mais quand
je tournais des fois ça se lever d'un
demi cran et je me dis si ça se trouve
il fallait pas c'était des points de
blocage où il fallait pas insisté mais
je forçais comme sa petite porte comme
ça pas comme ça elle est un farceur non
la ta force et pas trop regarder
rapprochement là sa force
attend lui lui bouge plus que tout à
l'heure le
g2o lui bouge pas lui il bouge et si je
le bouge il bouge après ensemble ils
peuvent semer d'alizée alors attends il
est ou au départ il est tous là si je
fais ça
je sais même pas si j'en suis pas qu'à
la première étape est ce qu ils
considèrent que c'est un mouvement tout
ce que j'aime faire qu'il ya ça qui
s'est un tout petit peu décalé
l'intérieur issu du milieu naturel avant
c'était tout lisse à ça la barre
centrale heure centrale s'est décalé
cantat machin ouais là on est bien
d'accord là tu me vois le relief où
effectivement et un petit relief comme
le massif central attends attends
attends j'ai avec mon doigt je sais pas
si c'est légal ans que je souhaite en
train de casser le tribut non mais c'est
ça qui m'agace c'est que je sais jamais
si avec les clips je ne sais jamais si
si c'est bien ou pas qu'est ce que je
fais ou appuyez sur le bouton
qu'est ce que j'en sais sur le bouton
pas
après s'il est ouvert je veux dire il
est ouvert quoi
c'est tout c'est tout c'est toute
l'année passée 3-0 je ne passais 3h30
dessus moi c'est tout bon alors c'est
quoi cette petite mais on a senti que
c'est le fait d'ouvrir sa part donné un
nom mais c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon
c'est bon on alarme et ben voilà et en
fait il fallait juste relevé hu et
pourquoi ça n'arriverait pas du coup à
huy parce que ça projeter non je
comprends même pas ce que j'ai fait tu
comprends même pas ce que j'ai réussi à
faire et bien sûr merci encore à ubud
avoir sponsorisé cette vidéo n'hésitez
pas à les découvrir le service via le
lien qui dans la description ça ne
change pas depuis dix ans et dans la
description je vais te laisser cette
chute la fais ce que tu veux moi je vais
mourir après si tu peux me réanimer du
coup je m'auto mettrait en pls tu peu
après mme réanimer quant à vous merci
d'avoir regardé cette vidéo si vous
voulez que me voir un jour je crois que
j'ai besoin de contacts humains parce
que ces objets là me font du mal donc si
vous voulez me voir quand je fais une
rencontre par chez vous ou quand je fais
un spectacle où des dédicaces ou un
tournage inscrivez-vous il ya le
le lien dans la description c'est moi
qui vous prévient maintenant j'ai décidé
pour 2022 de reprendre le contact humain
vous inscrivez vous mettez votre code
postal je vous préviens quand je viens à
prêt à manger je vous dirai ce que je
mange ou pas et puis je me préparais à
l'islamic ses poèmes mais celui-là bravo
aux créateurs ça doit être un travail
incroyable et c'est fou tout ce qu'il a
fait vraiment bravo à lui mais alors je
le déteste un peu quand même leur
montrer un casse tête bien celui qu'ils
ignorent menthe et bien ce sera sorti
toc et pis c'est tout ici deux autres
casquettes et une tête de loïc des
bisous à la famille
des bisous à la mère de luke dans les
commentaires à très bientôt de charles